Все так буденно, наче метро побудували. Історичний момент - країна стає ядерною державою!
Подивімося визначення ядерної держави. Це країна, в якої є ядерна зброя.
В нас 7 листопада з'явилась ядерна зброя. Та невже?
Білоруську АЕС зводили сім років. 7 листопада Олександр Лукашенко офіційно відкрив АЕС.
Дозвольте збільшити електричне навантаження енергоблоку з поточного значення 370 мегават до чотирьохсот.
Ну, звичайно, скільки чекали цього моменту, збільшуй.
Лукашенко довів, що цей об'єкт має для нього виключно політичне значення.
Тобто він до нього ставиться, як до зброї якоїсь, як до чогось такого,
що його може врятувати від якихось злих сил.
Терміни запуску не раз відкладалися, в тому числі через інциденти на АЕС.
Наприклад, у 2016 році на будмайданчику обвалилася бетонна конструкція.
А у липні того ж року корпус реактора під час його переміщення прослизнув по стропах і торкнувся землі.
В обох випадках білоруська влада не одразу визнала факт інцидентів.
В Білорусі критики АЕС вважають її не лише екологічно небезпечною.
Ця атомна станція невідомо, як будувалась, все у режимі закритості. Вже точно відомо, що будувалась із порушеннями.
Вже зараз відомо, що її пуск відбувається за відсутності ліцензії і для цього змінили законодавство.
За законом скасували ліцензію, тобто для введення в експлуатацію вона потрібна, а для запуску достатньо дозволу.
Саме тому атомна станція становить загрозу для Литви. В разі аварії литовцям доведеться евакуювати свою столицю.
Вільнюс розташований лише за 50 кілометрів від БілАЕС.
Мешканцям Вільнюса ще у жовтні в аптеках видали таблетки йоду - про всяк випадок.
Литва ще у 2017 році ухвалила закон про заборону постачання енергії з небезпечних АЕС в інших країнах.
Це геополітичний проєкт, це усім зрозуміло. Метою нашого закону було знизити економічну залежність від цього проєкту,
аби він ніколи не став комерційно прибутковим.
БілАЕС буде виробляти більше електроенергії, ніж потрібно самій країні.
Білорусь зацікавлена в її експорті, адже на будівництво Росія надала позику в 10 мільярдів доларів, яку треба повертати.
Головна проблема цього об'єкту полягає в тому, що він не має економічного значення. І небезпечний екологічно.
Його будівництво не потрібне Білорусі, не потрібне нікому. Воно потрібне лише Росії.
Для путінської Росії - це шлях розширити геополітичний вплив.
Путін та його оточення вважають, що чим більше буде таких об'єктів, тим більше ці країни будуть залежати від Росії,
що по суті правда, тому що цим країнам треба буде мати справу з ядерними відходами, з російськими ядерними технологіями.
Окрім країн Балтії, у Білорусі є лише два інших потенційних напрямки для експорту. Перший - Росія, в якої вистачає своєї електрики.
Другий - Україна, яка також покриває свої потреби внутрішньою генерацією, передусім атомною.
На початку року Україна імпортувала електроенергію з Росії та Білорусі, але з квітня-травня припинила це робити.
В українському Міністерстві енергетики заявляють, що не бачать сенсу в імпорті електроенергії, а навпаки Україна зацікавлена її експортувати.
В Білорусі теоретично може з'явитися варіант експорту до Євросоюзу після 2023 року, коли країни Балтії та Україна
завершать синхронізацію з європейською енергосистемою. Але стосовно цих поставок струму з Білорусі наразі більше запитань, ніж відповідей.
Найкоротша відстань від Островця до кордону України - близько 400 кілометрів, до Києва - понад 600.
Тож питання про ризики для українців від потенційної аварії на БілАЕС наразі ніким не порушується.
А як ставляться до АЕС у самому містечку Островець?
Люди звикли, що їхня думка нікого не цікавить. Лише одиниці, відчайдухи, які готові ризикнути чимось,
в тому числі особистими речами, борються проти цього, розуміючи,
що це не благо, а зло, м'яко кажучи. А в більшості своїй людям байдуже.
Активісти, які більше десяти років виступали проти будівництва АЕС, нині вбачають своє головне завдання в моніторингу.
Через кілька днів після підключення АЕС стало відомо про зупинку турбіни.
Активісти кажуть, що причиною стали вибухи трансформаторів напруги.